Please let me hold it. You'll let me hold it won't you? It's not weird. Girlfriends ask to do it all the time and it's not like it's dirty or anything.
Even if it was, we can go wash it quickly with some warm water or I can get a bottle and scooch it.
I honestly don't care if it's been a while since you've washed. If anything, the muskiness makes it nicer.
Oh come on. I'm using my manners. I'm saying pretty please. I could demand it but I won't because that's not polite so why are you holding back from me?
Did I upset you recently? Have I done something wrong? Then why aren't you letting me hold it while you pee?
It's a simple request really. I mean, I can't really explain why I want to do it. I just do.
Look, if I type it in on Google, there are tons of girls just like me who want to hold it while you tingle.
Okay, it's simple. It's not weird or anything and you wouldn't be mean and call me weird.
No, you're nice and kind so come on then. Let me hold it.
We can go to the bathroom right now, I'm serious. Or if you're feeling lazy, we can do it the game away and well, inside a bowl.
I don't care either way. Have we not been dating long enough for this or something?
Don't understand then why you won't let me.
Boundaries, are you serious? I'm practically begging you to let me do this and you're stating that boundaries are what's holding us back.
You're not serious, are you?
Are you not hydrated enough? Is that it? I don't mind if it's kind of apple juicy.
I can just get some water for you from the corner shop or you can drink it straight from the tap, you know, recancellages.
Or I have some dilute if that would make a difference. It's not like I have a BH strip to taste the sample with or anything.
We'll just flush it when you're finished and I can even give him a quick wash in the sink if there's that much of a problem for you.
Or I could use my face wipes.
So come on, please, let me hold that worry for me, for your girlfriend.
I can use one hand or even two, I don't mind.
Either way, the details do not matter as long as it's me, you and well, me holding it.
I'm sorry for whatever I did to annoy you.
You've been up for a few hours now and I've noticed that you've not used the bathroom, so you must be bursting.
Seriously, it must be all in your head if you feel like that you don't need to go.
Your power platter must be ready to pop. Do you know how silly and dangerous that can be?
Well, you must be relieved that you have me then, because I can keep you nice and healthy.
So let's go to the bathroom.
Okay, I mean, what better way to be treated like a king than you have someone to help you go number one.
It will prove how intimate we are with each other as well.
I could go practice all my friends in the group chat.
Uh, no, this didn't start because of them.
Well, maybe a little.
We were talking about the weird things that you do with your significant other.
And apparently it's really common to hold a fireman's hose while he sprays the water, you know?
So I thought we could do it.
I didn't think I would have to actually be begging for permission to do it though.
I love you very much, so if you love me, you let me hold it, okay? End of story.
Think of all the things that we've done together, both wholesome and otherwise.
And this, this is a step too far for you.
I quite literally don't have a single boundary with you.
I'm an open book.
That's what makes a relationship so special that we don't have to hesitate when asking for it needs to be met.
And I assure you, me holding it is a need, okay?
No, I want not a desire.
This act alone will prove our love and intimacy for one another, alright?
So come on, unzip your trussars.
Name something in return that you'd want me to have.
I could give you nightly massages for like a week.
Or one of those stingly ASMR sessions, huh?
Come on.
I can even buy some resources for them, like the Ear Cleaner Toolkits.
You know I'd be willing to do that for you, without even a moment of hesitation.
So you let me hold it, right?
This isn't fair.
Is it because of the way I'm asking?
Please, may you let me hold it.
I wish to be the holder of my stuff.
I desire to be your designated bathroom assistant.
Only for a number one, though.
If you do it, it would be so worth it.
I promise you, it really would be.
You might even ask for me to do it again in a strange twist of fate.
So please, let me hold it while you beat.
You're starting to test me.
This isn't fair.
How am I not worthy?
Do I need to solve some cryptic puzzle to prove that I've got enough wisdom for you to do this?
Or is it that you've seen me begging?
Is that it?
Is that what this is all about?
You're actually such a stinky mini.
What the heck?
Just give me out already.
I am not guilt-tripping you because I'm crying.
I'm actually genuinely upset at the revelation that our relationship is so shallow
that your girlfriend asking you to hold it is such a trivial matter to you even though I've communicated otherwise.
That's it.
I'll just annoy you until you break.
You don't deserve the nice me, okay?
Only the mean me because you're a mini and you'll get what you deserve, okay?
Only stinky boys don't say yes to their girlfriends and you know that this is a bid for affection and you're ignoring it on purpose.
You are a mini boobini.
You hear me?
If I say please, the rule should be that you bend over backwards for me.
Now you're just looking at me all smug while I'm annoyed.
Is this an insurance test?
We've already been at this for how long now?
I assure you that I can go a heck of a lot longer than you as our bedroom visits suggest.
You are taller than me.
You are bigger than me.
Are you scared of me or something?
Well, four.
I'm literally the perfect height to be an ankle biter.
You're actually lucky that I can refrain from spitting in your ears right now.
It's only because I want something from you.
I would never go that low but just think to yourself you could have a girlfriend that could but no, you've got me, the perfect girlfriend.
Just know that if you seek anything from me, I'm gonna remember this moment.
Remember that I was pleading and begging with you and getting all worked up when you smail at me with that dumb expression.
I'm sorry, okay?
I didn't mean any of it, please just let me grasp it or let me give you war or anything.
I can't stand it when you don't interact with me and just look at me.
Baby, please, I need you.
I'm sorry, I got you all those mean things.
You know I said that stuff because I'm desperate, okay?
Please, please, I just need this one thing, this one tiny and significant silly thing.
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please.
Please, okay, please, I'm sorry for you on and please, please, please, please, please.
I am not falling asleep, okay?
I have the stamina of an ox, okay?
And I can do this all day and night long, okay?
Please, please, please, please, please, please.
Please, please, please, please, please, okay?
bzzzzzzzzzzzzzz
please, please, please
P-L-E-A-S-E
bzzzzzzzzz
bzzzz zzzzzz
please, please, please for me
please, please, please
I want it, please
please, please, please, please
please, please
p-p-p-p-p-p-please
for me
please, please, please
please for me, for me, for your girlfriend
for your crazy girlfriend
that really must tell that we
let me hold your fireman
wait, let me hold your whole house, Mr. Fireman
let me hold your house, let me hold your house
we love our girlfriend and we love when our girlfriend holds our house
there once was a girlfriend who wanted to hold a house
and that boyfriend said no
and she said please, please, please
I want to hold the house
and then she got to hold the house
and he lived happily ever after
and he got lots of kisses
and sometimes she even kisses him on his nose
as I thank you, because that's how it works
please, please
p-p-p-p-p-please
p-p-p-p-please
please, please
please
p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-p-
bu-b-ee
p-p-p-p- JAMES
my lungs are giving up because I've been paking you so long
by saying please
to show you my love and how much I want to hold it while you be, I'm going to say please
while expelling air in your earhole and you'll listen to how I've messed up my lungs are,
whilst I do it.
h-h-h-h-h-h-h...
but...
h-h...
please, please, please
please
please, please
pssss
come here
come here low penis
pssss
come to my hand
come
come come
please
pssss
pl-Pi-Pe-Pe-Bop
p-P поп
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please,
please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please,
please, please, please,
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please,
please